respond to the man who held the same
position during the Obama administration
currently an economics professor at the
University of Chicago Booth School of
Business fantastic school by the way is
Austin Goolsbee Austin tell us why
should we be discouraged by a good gdp
number which to listen to some of the
commentary today it's like you want to
you know take a Prozac and this is like
great news and so many of these
Democrats just could not they couldn't
deal with the positive news for the
country or for Trump which to me seemed
very sad yeah look I'm gonna agree with
you I do find that sad and you could see
that there were a bunch of Democrats who
are just trying to spin it in a partisan
way there's nothing bad about having a
4% GDP growth number that's good that's
good for America and the president is
entitled to say this was a good number
you could see he was he was beaming with
pride the question now is how can we
continue to sustain it it is worth
remembering just last quarter was a
pretty mediocre number so we had around
2% now we got 4% let's hope we get more
4% and not return to the 2% but III
don't think there's anything that you
should convince yourself that was bad
about this number it wasn't bad we
aren't seeing wages rise as we we want
especially with a tight labor market you
would think that wages would begin
that's a real up Tiger II that's a
problem that's been flatlining for 18
years we haven't seen real wages think
we're seeing a lot of bonuses though
which is which is nice to see but people
don't seem as more operations as we
should but I go look that that's the the
toughest part of the recovery and it has
been true for a long time it's not like
this is just a fault of the Trump
administration it's been a long period
that we haven't had enough wage growth
for just ordinary workers right in the
middle of the of the wage distribution
if you want to think about it now that's
it that doesn't take away from the GDP
today the GDP today is very good but I
just just be a little careful there are
several aspects of the
GDP number today that look like they're
probably temporary we're still growing
pretty well but there's this some parts
of it that remember is remember the
increase in trade hasn't really kicked
in yet I mean when when this European
deal gets done
yeah I understand NAFTA is going to get
done here my sources are telling me
but if NAFTA gets done which it looks
much more likely now which I can't
believe I'm saying that but it does
that's all I every trade war is a good
day for America yeah I am right on that
and I'll have you back but let's play
there's just something fun that happened
this week
Bob Lloyd Heiser US trade rep was on
Capitol Hill and he was in front of the
Senate committee and of course lots of
critics on both sides about these
tariffs and how we're trying to take on
China this is Brian Schatz Democrat from
Hawaii let's watch first of all you sit
you say the Chinese are clever because
they have a 50-year view we should be
clever and happy two or three-year view
that doesn't make any sense to me I
believe that no I'm saying we're a
democracy and so we take a shorter term
view because we are responsible to our
voters periodically so does that mean
that democracy's always lose to
authoritarian governments does that mean
the state capital no it just does that
mean sir it just means you don't pick
stupid fights if look if your conclusion
is that China taking over all of our
technology in the future of our children
is a stupid fight then you are right we
should capitulate my view is that's how
we got where we are so I don't think
it's a stupid fight I didn't get enough
play but I thought that was that
encapsulated so much of what the Trump
economic agenda is all about don't cede
to China
don't be part of the China surrender
caucus fight for every job fight for
every opportunity and light hyzer is an
underrated rockstar in this
administration close it out all I would
say is if your main thing is about
confronting China don't pick seven
fights while carrying a six-shooter
that's the gun fighters credo and that's
been our problem our natural allies to
stop Chinese intellectual property
violation
would be the fairy countries that were
threatening trade wars with so they're
all working with us the EU is working
with us on a new deal they are not all
working with us now Korea cut a deal
months ago they did they cut a new deal
months ago Europe's already
renegotiating with us Mexico's about to
renegotiate NAFTA Canada slowly but
surely realizing all is done it's done
in steel and the Europeans are joining
with China to file grievances against us
at the just not even find a way to
confront China to help us
wait it's roughly house right all right
it's the right time we're gonna we're
gonna roll roll block again Laura it is
great to have you on as alway